[Music]
a handwritten letter is a sure way to
make someone smile
especially if it comes from a totally
unexpected place
whether it's from the top of the
mountains or the middle of the ocean
there's always a way to write to your
loved ones
[Music]
i'm wim krouswick i collect messages in
bottles
from the beach in 34
years i collected over 1200
messages in bottles
i have all the time in the world and
instead of talking with other old people
i love to walk on the beach and see the
surprises
[Music]
in 1983 i found three of them so i wrote
them
that i was surprised to find these
messages and
the other surprise was that i got
answers of all three of them
and that's when i decided okay i'm a
collector
of messages in bottles
i find my messages in bottles on the
beach of sanford where i live
and on the dutch islands messages in
bottles is slow mail
it takes you days weeks or months
to find a bottle
and i don't even on the beach open them
i put them in my
rug pack and at home i open them
to have a second surprise this is the
german girl
the first letter she wrote me on the
28th
of august in 1983.
it pleased me to receive your letter
is something you can think about what
you're writing
when you're talking with somebody you're
interrupted and getting an answer before
you
expect it when you write something you
can write
on your own nobody is interrupting you
and when you get an answer
i cannot interrupt them
even when i have been writing only a few
times with somebody i got to know him
and when i'm going through this
collection and i see the message
then i remember how much fun we had for
a while
[Music]
one afternoon in 1999 mr matsumoto had
an idea
that idea would put his small town of
susami
on the map
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
in a classic if you build it they will
come story
they built it and people came
in
this is mr nakanishi he runs the dive
shop here in susami and he manages the
postbox
[Music]
poster
since the box is underwater you can't
just mail a typical postcard
so it goes like this you come into mr
nakanishi's dad shop
buy a postcard write your note
[Music]
gear up dive down slip the note into the
red mailbox
sitting on the ocean floor and according
to mr nakanishi
it will actually get to its destination
[Music]
today
[Music]
made susami a destination for divers it
made the town special
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
history
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
tucked away in india's northern state of
himachal pradesh is an area called the
spiti valley
which translates as the middle land this
mountainous region bordering india and
tibet is strikingly beautiful
but incredibly remote in fact it's one
of the most sparsely populated regions
in all of india
but even here in the small remote
village of hikkim
there is one building that you might
find very familiar
[Music]
open 12 months a year every day from 10
to 4 the post office
is actually a part of rinchen's home so
the commute
is pretty easy
[Music]
japanese
[Music]
foreign
on top of distributing letters ringchen
also handles passports for the locals in
town and all
of the money deposits and withdrawals
even though the post office is small
he still needs some help
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign